nos preguntan cuál de las siguientes
opciones describe el lugar del punto en
la recta numérica y aquí está el punto
aquí tenemos el 1 y entre el 1 y el 2
tenemos estas divisiones tenemos 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 lo que significa que cada
división o cada rayita es un décimo
entonces veamos el número en el que está
este puntito tenemos aquí un entero y 0
décimas un entero y una décima un entero
dos décimas un entero tres décimas y un
entero cuatro décimas así que tenemos
aquí un entero cuatro décimas esa es una
de las opciones y que de las demás
opciones
podemos contar cada una de las décimas
desde el cero hasta el punto y tenemos
una dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete
ocho nueve diez y aquí tiene sentido
porque diez décimas es un entero
seguimos 11 12 13 14 décimas esta opción
también es correcta y que hay de esta
opción uno entero cuatro centésimas
bueno esto está a otra escala está en
centésimas y aquí tenemos décimas para
tener centésimas tendríamos que dividir
cada uno de estos segmentos en diez
partes iguales cada una así que este un
entero cuatro centésimas no estaría más
o menos por acá entonces esto no aplica
vamos a comprobar la respuesta
hagamos algunas preguntas más
enteros una décima es equivalente a
cuantas décimas bueno recordemos que un
entero es igual a diez décimas aquí
tenemos dos enteros por lo tanto son 20
décimas serían 20 décimas más una décima
que ya tenemos aquí serían 21 décimas
comprobamos respuestas
es correcta hagamos la siguiente
pregunta cómo podemos escribir tres
enteros cuatro décimas con letra
recordamos que un entero es igual a diez
décimas dos enteros son veinte décimas y
tres enteros son treinta décimas y aquí
tenemos cuatro décimas treinta décimas
más cuatro décimas son treinta y cuatro
décimas sería esta opción centésimas no
porque aquí no estamos hablando de
centésimas para que esto fueran
centésimas tendrían que ser 3.40 o
tendrían que ser 340 centésimas cosa que
no es y 34 unidades pues bueno aquí
tenemos nuestra división decimal son
tres enteros o tres unidades no 34 y
aquí cuatro décimas así que esta es
nuestra opción correcta comprobamos
respuesta es correcta hagamos algunos
problemas más nos dicen cada cuadrado
grande debajo representa un entero
cada uno de esos cuadrados representa un
entero cuál de las siguientes opciones
representa el área de color elige todas
las opciones correctas veamos primero
tenemos que ver en cuanto está dividido
cada cuadro tenemos que aquí hay uno dos
tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho nueve
diez cuadritos un renglón está dividido
en diez cuadritos cuántos renglones hay
uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete
ocho nueve diez 10 x 10 son 100 cada
cuadro grande está dividido en
centésimas y aquí tenemos un entero
completo es decir 100 centésimas
hay que otro entero completo iluminado y
aquí cuánto tenemos iluminado en
centésimas quedamos que cada renglón son
10 centésimas por lo que tenemos un
renglón dos renglones tres renglones
cuatro renglones
a 40 centésimas entonces si contamos
todas las centésimas esto es igual a 100
240 240 centésimas ahora que hay de
estas otras dos opciones bueno vamos a
ver estas 24 centésimas
esta no nos sirve porque son 24
centésimas y ya contamos que las que
están iluminadas son 240 esta no es
ahora dos enteros con 40 centésimas
vemos que estos cuadritos que son
enteros pues tenemos dos de estos
cuadros totalmente iluminados tenemos
dos enteros completos
recordemos que 100 centésimas es un
entero aquí tenemos 100 centésimas o un
entero
otras 100 centésimas dos enteros y aquí
tenemos cuántas centésimas aquí hay dos
enteros y aquí tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22
23 24 25 26 27 28 29 30 31 32 33 34 35
36 37 38 39 y 40
40 centésimas 2 enteros 40 centésimas
que es esta opción checamos nuestra
respuesta
es correcta hagamos otro problema más
cómo podemos escribir 2 enteros 60
centésimas con letra 260 centésimas si
recordamos que un entero en centésimas
son 100 100 centésimas son un entero
aquí tenemos dos enteros pues van a ser
doscientas centésimas y aquí tenemos de
por sí 60 centésimas
entonces 260 centésimas podría ser la
siguiente opción dos unidades bueno esta
parte es correcta dos unidades y dos
unidades pero aquí me dicen seis
centésimas y aquí tengo sesenta
centésimas que no es lo mismo y aquí son
doscientos sesenta décimas pero no esto
de aquí no son doscientos sesenta
décimas para tener doscientos sesenta
décimas si recordamos que diez décimas
es un entero aquí tenemos 26 enteros y
no es lo que tenemos aquí así
esta es nuestra opción correcta
comprobamos respuesta y efectivamente es
correcta hagamos un ejercicio más
escribe un número decimal que sea
equivalente a treinta y siete décimas
entonces son treinta y siete décimas
esto lo puedo escribir como treinta
décimas más siete décimas
estas 30 décimas si recordamos que 10
décimas es un entero 20 décimas serán
dos enteros 30 décimas serán tres
enteros así que aquí puedo poner un 3
más 7 décimas
y estas siete décimas las puedo expresar
como punto 7
3.7 son tres enteros siete décimas
comprobamos respuestas
es correcta hagamos un ejercicio más
cuál de las siguientes opciones describe
el lugar del punto en la recta numérica
es muy parecido al primer ejercicio un
entero dos enteros y entre cada entero
tenemos uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis
siete ocho nueve diez divisiones tenemos
décimas aquí tenemos un entero cero
décimas un entero una décima un entero
dos décimas un entero tres décimas un
entero cuatro décimas un entero cinco
décimas un entero seis décimas un entero
siete décimas y un entero ocho décimas
así que está de 1.8 me sirve que otras
opciones me pueden servir pues de igual
manera podemos contar cada una de las
décimas que van aquí uno dos tres cuatro
cinco seis siete ocho nueve diez
11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 18 que 18
décimas y aquí 18 centésimas no la
considero porque centésimas implica que
cada una de mis décimas cada una de
estas divisiones a su vez estaría
dividida en diez partes iguales y esto
no es lo que tenemos aquí así que ésta
no aplica comprobamos respuesta es
correcta hagamos un problema más como
podemos escribir 2.02 con letra este 0-2
significa que si este es el lugar de las
décimas pues no tengo ninguna décima y
este es el lugar de las centésimas y
tengo dos centésimas estos son dos
enteros o dos unidades
tengo dos enteros dos centésimas aquí
son doscientos dos décimas no esto no
aplica porque aquí estoy hablando de
centésimas
si fueran doscientos dos décimas tendría
que ser veinte dos y no es esto está no
es dos unidades y dos décimas no tampoco
quedamos que aquí en lugar de mis
décimas está vacío
202 centésimas esto sí me suena a que es
correcto porque dos enteros o dos
unidades en términos de centésimas van a
ser un entero son 100 centésimas dos
enteros son 200 centésimas más estas dos
centésimas que teníamos aquí doscientos
dos centésimas comprobamos respuestas
es correcta y creo que hemos resuelto
bastantes ejercicios